à 14 ans lina fait ses devoirs tout seul
une tâche pas si simple pour cette jeune
adolescente atteint de trisomie 21 en
classe de 4è lille a un emploi du temps
bien chargé
elle doit composer entre sa classe
ordinaire et la classe ulis unité
localisée d'inclusion scolaire des
classes particulières avec très peu
d'élèves est en situation de handicap
s'est fait la malle et je suis fait
lecture et c'est
écriture sa mère toujours derrière elle
en cas de besoin voit sa fille
progresser et prendre de l'autonomie un
sport j'ai fait j'ai fait frisbee et
elle t'a pas oublié un mot devant j'ai
fait mais les frisbee ou du frisbee
contenu c'est mieux alors maternelle on
lui donnait même pas des ciseaux parce
qu'on pensait qu'elle savait pas des
coupes des coupes et alors qu'elle
savait le faire en fait cessé
voilà c'est compliqué parce que les
personnes ne croient pas forcément en
elle parce qu'il ya une trisomie 21 et
qu'ils connaissent pas forcément
lina suit aussi des cours en segpa des
cours d'enseignement professionnel
adapté qui lui permettent de développer
son projet professionnel
car à 14 ans lina sait déjà ce qu'elle
veut faire plénière et cp tarte aux
pommes étaient pda
et c'est qui ça lui plaît et du coup ça
devient un projet et puis et puis là
elle a vraiment pris à son compte
puisqu'elle veut ouvrir un restaurant
elle prépare des cartes de restaurants
donc c'est quelque chose qui lui tient à
coeur dans son collège à fontenay le
fleury l'enseignante ulysse en charge de
li na lui fournit des apprentissages
ciblé deux niveaux ce2 et plus encore
elle lui donne des exercices en lien
avec son projet professionnel pour
travailler la durée
je m'appuie sur la cuisson cuisine pour
travailler la monnaie sur peut être sur
une des achats d'ingrédients li na est
arrivé il ya trois ans dans ce collège
elle est suivie par là même enseignante
pour créer un lien de confiance les
besoins glina c'est d'abord un accueil
en salle de dispositifs individualisé
vers d'autres vont arriver ont posé
leurs sacs et hop
li na c'est vrai qu'elle a besoin que ce
soit avec la msa show avec moi bond un
bon jour
ul ensuite tout ce qui est le langage
lui permettre de faire évoluer son
lexique les mollets les d'exprimer ses
émotions
li na s'est rapidement fait des amis au
sein de ce dispositif ulis lina elle a
beaucoup apportés au dispositif
c'est une personnalité vraiment et j'ai
beaucoup appris moi en tant que
professionnel j'ai appris beaucoup de
l'ina en fin de troisième la collégienne
devra passer un diplôme le certificat de
formation générale
présentation d'un dossier sur un centre
d'intérêt ou un stage à l'oral pour
pouvoir ensuite rentré dans une ulis au
lycée elle pourra continuer son
apprentissage de la cuisine et décrocher
d'ici là un diplôme dans la restauration